cinq quatre trois deux un silence on
tourne sujet du jour les hérons cendrés
qui sont majestueux c'est des grands
oiseaux plus grand oiseau noir et il
réside en partie en plein centre-ville
d'orléans depuis février ils sont là ils
vont être là jusqu'au mois de juillet
une niche dans les cimes des arbres qui
bordent le dui les hérons cendrés au
programme un spectacle magnifique
[Musique]
on est une fois de plus en plein centre
ville
et juste à regarder quand on est au
niveau de l'éclusé c'est en phase avec
une paire de jumelles on y voit tous
deux gros pôles avec des nids au total
il ya plus d'une trentaine de ni essai
ni de héron ils vont être occupés à
partir du mois de février à peu près ils
vont arriver pour reconstituer leur nid
et puis ils vont faire leur portée entre
fin février et jusqu'au mois de juillet
et ceni qui sont là ils sont en haut ils
sont loin des prédateurs pas que parce
qu'il ya quand même des prédateurs des
ronds et ils sont bien plus petit et ses
prédateurs là eh ben ils sont juste en
face ils ont élu domicile juste en face
c'est les corneilles et les corneilles
elles ont leur nid en face et
régulièrement on assiste à des combats
aériens de corneille qui viennent
surveillez les nids des hérons et qui
vont les attaquer soit pour bouffer les
oeufs soit pour attraper les petits et
bien souvent dans ces combats et arias
et les héros qui gagne quand même ce
qu'on trouve l'été quand les camps c'est
plus découvert sur les bancs de sable on
trouve quand même des cadavres de
corneille
ainsi va la loire
[Musique]
quand on tend bien l'oreille on entend
les pv qui captent du bec
ils ont faim ben c'est d'aller y voir de
plus près
[Musique]
d'une si petite coquille que va sortir
ce si grand oiseau un oeuf de héron
cendré
on est sous la héronnière alors il faut
faire attention parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de déjections il faudra bien se laver
les mains après et donc sous la
héronnière on a ici on entend à la fois
des caquètements des bébés on l'écrit
des corneilles qui les attaquent on
entend un petit peu les sternes aussi
parce qu'elles sont déjà là et c est
rond on va les trouver
principalement ici en centre-ville on
les voit très souvent d'ailleurs les
promeneurs du dimanche vous êtes
habitués à les voir on peut les
approcher très près parce qu'ils sont
devenus assez citadins mais on les
trouve aussi à la pêche sur le bord du
lit ou sur les bords de la loi puis
également alors je sais dans les étangs
des propriétaires solognot et des
petites parts il aime pas je sais bon il
faut de tout pour faire un monde
et puis on les trouve aussi dans les
champs parce que le héron il va pas
manger uniquement les poissons il va
aussi se nourrir le petit mulot ou de
petites de petits animaux qui va
attraper aussi c'est à la fois un
chasseur et pêcheur d'une si petite
coquille n'est ainsi magnifiques oiseaux
merci la loire